نعم موجود اثبت يعني الفن السعودي اثبت
وجوده في الساحه العربيه على ماذا تقوم
هذه الهويه عندنا في الفن التشكيلي
السعودي دائما بتشوف مثلا بالفن السعودي
اهتمام بالخط العربي
كثير تدخل في الاعمال الفنيه الخطوط وهي
موجوده وهي موجوده ايضا من حرف الخط
العربي خط جميل يعني
انا درست الخط لا اعتبر نفسي خطاطه لا
درجه الخط اخذت في دورات لكن
هو جزء من هويتنا وثقافتنا اللغه كتابه
اللغه الحروف
تجانسها في اللوحه في المساحه شيء جميل
وكم امراه سعوديه انت كمان معلمه معلمه
نعم قلتي لي يعني قبل الحلقه انه كمان انا
عندي قلق من
يعني من الطالبات او من نظره الطالبات
الجيل الجديد
ليش حاله القلق هذه موجوده عندك ضياع
الهويه تشبه بالغرب الكثير
لكل دوله او لكل امه لها هويتها الخاصه
فيها تجعلها قويه ومتفرده
تمازج
[موسيقى]
الحضارات او الثقافات
تمازج الثقافات شيء مهم جدا لكن
لازم ننتبه انه في حد نوقف عنده انه لا
هذه ثقافتي هذه هويتي ما اتعدى يعني ما
ادخل
بقوه
وانحرف في
هويات اخرى انت شايفه انه الجيل الجديد
فشيئا عن هويته نعم قاعد يبتعد وهل هناك
دور معين يجب ان تقوم به مؤسسه توجيهات
عندنا لمحاوله مواجهه هذه الاشكاليه يعني
جهودها مستمره جميع المؤسسات انا يعني
من المنبر التعليم جدا
مهتمين بهذا الشيء
والحمد لله
رائحه زهره الفلفل والياسمين
الجبل والروزماري
ما كان نكتب بالغي في في حاله الخوف يمكن
شغفي انا وحبي يدفعني للمبالغه بهذا الشيء
ممكن هناك شيء نوع من المبالغه كلامك صحيح
وين مظاهر الابتعاد اللي انت شايفتها كخطر
اليوم
مقلق
مثلا لو ناخذ من ناحيه اللغه كثير بيحكي
لي انا معلمه لغه انجليزيه ليه ما تتكلمين
انجليزي دائما تتكلمين عربي
انه ليه اتكلم عربي انا اهتم بقوميتي
جمال لغتي
يعني اللي اشوف الكثير الان قاعد يهتم
باللغه الانجليزيه على اللغه العربيه هذا
جانب حلو هذا احد الجوانب الاخرى
احدى الجوانب جوانب اخرى مثلا
معاها انا مع الحضاره بالعكس ما احب
التخلف ولا ادعو له ادعو الى التمدد
والتحضر
لكن ليس بهذه الطريقه مثلا اذا تكلمنا عن
اللغه الدراسه
اللبس يعني زي ما اقول لك انا الموروث
يعني لما تروح دول اخرى اشياء بسيطه رموز
عندهم يحافظون عليها
احنا ما شاء الله عندنا موروث كبير في
المملكه وفي الدول الخليج ايضا مش بس
المملكه والدول العربيه الاسلاميه
فلازم نحافظ عليه